sometimes watching a movie just won't do
you also want to eat that movie that's
why there's movie recipe today we're
going to show you how to make a Terrence
Malick's - that is a stew that tastes
exactly like a Terrence Malick film
let's get started
any good stew starts with the broth and
you can use chicken broth if you want
but I'm gonna go with beef just pour
that in there Malik loves water so we
definitely have to include a good dose
of water terrence malick movies
regardless of the topic always star
beautiful people so we need to replicate
that beauty in our stew and what better
way to do that than with the brand that
most represents beauty Dov so for our
recipe you need one standard dove bar
just plop it in you might be wondering
about protein as a good stew always has
meat but terrence malick movies don't so
this two will be meatless I repeat
meatless no Terrence Malick's two would
be complete without his single favorite
ingredient tree branches
I recommend you get at least two or
three different kinds of branches just
so you can add some layering into the
flavor the secret ingredient in this
week's dish is nutmeg because it thinks
it's more important than it really is
now you want to let a good terrence
malick babysit for as long as you
possibly can at at least eight hours but
if you can wait as long as 20 years make
sure you stir frequently am i stirring
the students at stirring me then simply
serve and enjoy mmm pointless
[Music]